all right what's going on
revolutionaries
because that's what you are if you're
watching this freedom loving show you
are now
a revolutionary because it's getting
stupider
i am here live in los angeles
i'm fairly certain i just broke the law
i took clyde out for a walk
he had to poop and i felt it would be
best
if we got him a little exercise you know
these boxers he's part boxer
part pit a lot of energy i didn't feel
like letting him go in the yard you know
that can be boring just walking around
the same grass all the time
so i took my dog for a walk there were
snipers garcetti's got snipers on the
roofs
of all the buildings and we had to avoid
the sniper fire
clyde pooped i went to get the poop they
were shooting down at the poop
i was able to grab the poop because that
would be another infringement if you
don't pick up
the dog poop so i was able to grab the
poop we made it back alive we're okay
but i'm fairly certain i i did break the
law uh we're going to talk about these
idiotic draconian authoritarian
at this point psychotic lockdowns that
these people have no constitutional
right to do it's getting worse and worse
and worse
in la and that 75 degree weather
75 to 82 degree weather that we have
here every day it's starting to not
become
as pleasant uh and starting to not
become as good a reason to be here
because this is absolutely ridiculous
uh i should tell you guys though that um
while i did i think break the law by
walking my dog this morning and again i
i'll be judged in a court of law for
that
um i do have my producer michael and my
director connor here in studio and uh
you know the other day i had them wave
here why don't we have you wait guys
wave again i don't want people to think
we're just making this stuff up okay so
i've got other humans here we're in a
small room
now we're on complete lockdown you're
not allowed to have people in your house
blah blah blah now this is my house
but and we'll get to this in a little
bit there are some exemptions and that
includes podcasts
and now i understand that what i do here
is probably the most important thing in
the world
more important than people that are
performing heart surgery or you know
curing cancer or the rest of it but but
really think how silly it is that
podcasting has been decided to be exempt
that's how
like nonsensical these rules are like
but not just like political podcasting
as if we have to
exempt people that are getting you the
news like you could be an unboxer
or a video game podcaster and that's
exam two but if you're an accountant who
wants to go to the office
no we're gonna we're gonna haul you in
it's all just bananas
so all right we're going to obviously
talk about the lockdown
i have my glasses so i have a special
message for
uh mayor eric garcetti i also have this
the constitution people i've got a i've
got a pocket constitution
if you would have told me five years ago
that progressive
lefty dave rubin would be one of the
guys walking around with the pocket
constitution you know there's always
like this old republican
and they're at the senate he's like i've
got my pocket constitution and then this
document i'm now that guy i'm that guy
i'm going to literally walk around the
pocket constitution for now on so that
if i'm ever
accosted by one of these lunatics on the
street these garcetti thugs
come and get me guys all right so uh
we're obviously going to talk a lot
about lockdowns and and there are some
good signs
because although these lockdowns are
annoying there are some great signs
we're going to show you a couple of
videos
of people that are fighting back and
it's exciting and it's awesome and it's
everything that america
is really all about as opposed to what
these people are doing which is the most
anti-american thing you could be doing
and then we're going to start today by
talking about some of the voter fraud
stuff because there's a lot happening
and you're not seeing it on cnn and
and again this reality war that i'm
always talking about if stuff's
happening there are hearings happening
in pennsylvania
and in arizona and in michigan there are
all these hearings happening there are
people who have
signed affidavits saying that they
have seen fraud giving specific evidence
trump's lawyers
made some pretty extreme claims
yesterday that were then submitted to
the court so
we're going to show you some video on
that but if you don't hear about any of
that
and then it starts going through the
system and then it's two weeks from now
and suddenly everyone's like whoa maybe
something really did happen
well then you're going to be set up to
to have a nervous breakdown and i think
half the country is
is heading in that direction in case
half the country's not having a nervous
breakdown now
so that's what we're going to be
covering today i am ready to roll like
i'm ready for the revolution i really am
like if this is what
these [ __ ] are going to do like
i'm i'm here for it like
i am not going to be your [ __ ] eric
garcetti you have no right to lock me
into my house
and i'm gonna live my life as i see fit
but before we get to all that let's talk
about glint pay guys i've been telling
you guys about glenpay and
if you don't know the world is in a very
precarious spot one of the things that's
lasted for a long time
that people have cared about for a long
time while that's gold and using your
glint pay
card you can not only buy and sell gold
but you can use your card which is also
a mastercard
to make purchases you could
you could buy a pocket constitution with
your glint pay card okay guys
you can buy anything that you could buy
with a normal mastercard you can do it
with your
pay card and you can either pay in usd
u.s dollars or you can pay in gold on
top of being able
to buy and sell gold as you see fit it's
a
really
interesting fun way of just trying to do
something a little bit different and be
a little bit
a little bit more in control of your
finances than just uh
then just trust in the standard systems
the glenn card is issued by
sutton bank which is a member of the
fdic pursuant to license from mastercard
international
it's free to sign up so go to
glintpay.com reuben
for more information and to start
purchasing gold today
that's glintpay.com reuben to get your
gold today
buy a pocket constitution with some gold
all right
before we get to the lockdown stuff
let's just get caught up on the election
stuff because i feel like it's getting
lost in the fray a little bit and by the
way i think that's by design i think one
of the reasons
that cnn and everybody else is going 24
hours a day on crazy
corona stuff and making it seem like the
world is ending tomorrow and the zombie
apocalypse is here
is because they they need to cover
something so that our eyes are not
on some of the voter fraud stuff so i'm
going to show you a video this is from
yesterday this is on maria bartoromo's
show
on fox business and this is trump lawyer
jesse bernal and he's going to lay out
some very specific things
that they submitted to the courts
yesterday
so again as i have said from the
beginning
it doesn't mean just because someone is
saying it is true
but now he's saying they have evidence
and it's been submitted to the court so
we will find out
but i want to show you this so that in a
week or so once this has gotten through
the courts
well we'll find out if it's true or not
you'll go oh i knew about it so let's
take a look
we are going to present evidence of real
voter fraud
thousands and thousands of instances in
voter fraud in nevada alone
by five o'clock today that will be
submitted to the court
and we have uh instances for instance of
40 000 plus people who have voted twice
in the election that's real voter fraud
we have
uh data showing that people who
were on the record as having voted by
mail
didn't even receive ballots and say that
they didn't vote
we have a lot of evidence that we are
going to be presenting to the court
showing that voters have been
disenfranchised nevada because
every single time there's a fraudulent
vote cast
put into the system it dilutes the votes
of of honest voters okay so there's a
bunch of
very specific stuff that according to
trump's lawyer they submitted
to the courts yesterday he is saying we
are presenting to the court over
40 000 people who voted twice in the
election
now we are about to find out if that is
true now if that is true
would that be voter fraud would that
would that lead people to be
disenfranchised from voting like the
answer
seems to be yes so if by me talking
about what the lawyers are saying
they're submitting to the courts and
have the evidence of if that makes me a
conspiracy theorist
or a deplorable or a general nut bag
well then here i am people
um i think it's worth talking about we
will now find out and again as i've said
from beat one
the lawyers that are that are doing this
stuff they either have a sense of what
they're doing
and they they know that they have some
evidence or they're self-immolating
right they're just lighting themselves
on fire and destroying their
careers and their personal lives and
everything else like this stuff doesn't
come with no cost
like forget forget the just destruction
of your own career if you're an attorney
that's either blatantly lying or making
up evidence or making up things or the
rest of it just think what you're doing
to your life
like you know we know about all the
death threats these people get
and you know the the amount of uh you
know people that would love to have them
fired or canceled or everything else
so that's one interesting thing that
happened yesterday that i'm guessing you
probably didn't hear about
and then uh let's take a look at this
other
video from yesterday this is from the
the michigan senate they're having a
hearing on what happened
voting irregularities in michigan and
this
is a poll supervisor uh her name
is uh she's a poll challenger sorry this
is a poll challenger
by the name of christina caramaro and
she's testifying here
that a poll supervisor illegally gave
contested votes
to democratic candidates listen to what
she says she's under oath as she is
doing this
and it doesn't mean that what she's
saying is true but you you
just use your own mind to say does it
does it sound like what this woman is
saying is true or not
and then and then if what she's saying
is true if they have evidence of it
would that change your feelings about
what happened in michigan let's take a
look
so i was a poll challenger at the tcf
center
on monday november 2nd 3rd and 4th
on november 4th early in the morning i
was standing at the adjudication table
and a ballot came across the screen the
ballot had a straight party ticket vote
for both the democrat and the republican
it was a filled in circle which is an
intentional mark it's not a dash it's
not a dot
when the ballot came across the screen
there was no other marksman of the
judges and none of the other
ballot proposals have been voted on the
poll worker then said
i think i'm going to give it to the
democrats that's absolutely absurd
that is illegal the vote should have
been tossed out at that moment i said
absolutely not i'm going to challenge
this
so i go get her supervisor and then her
supervisor defers to her and says
well what do you think and i'm like what
do you think it doesn't matter what you
think it's the law
our feelings our emotions our thoughts
are totally irrelevant you follow the
law
and that ballot is to be tossed out but
she wanted to give it to the democrats
so then
i go get the gentleman who was
overseeing the entire absentee ballot
counting process
while daniel baxter was gone so this
gentleman's name i do not know
i go get him he's overseeing the entire
process while daniel baxter is gone
i ask him he says to the girl what do
you think
it was disgusting i was enraged and i
simply asked a question i said
well why not give it to the republicans
instead of the democrats
the gentleman began screaming at me
began yelling at me began telling me
that i had no right to talk to her
and he told her to push the ballot
through and prior to that that same poll
worker
a ballot came across the adjudication
screen where this
voter had voted for joe biden and the
green party presidential candidate
and she gave the vote to joe biden i
also saw the ballots show up in the
middle of the night
also i inquired about the tabulation
numbers from the tabulation machine
between shift changes
i was denied that information we saw a
lot of irregular things this is not an
anomaly
just because all of us have different
accounts of what we saw that doesn't
make them invalid
and to expect secretary benson to
actually do something about it a
foolhardy
to accept uh to accept dan and essel to
do anything about it would be foolhardy
so we're appealing to you guys to do
something about it because if our
elections aren't fair then we have no
republic left
it's a banana republic we have nothing
and we don't trust the election process
why do you think a lot of people don't
vote
because they feel it's a big fraud i
want to go on the record here
under oath that i love this woman
christina camaro does that woman strike
you with someone that's lying does that
woman strike you as someone
that is not aware of what she's talking
about or is making stuff up i mean that
is some
specific stuff there you know how during
these lockdowns we don't get any
specific information from our government
officials you know they just tell us
what we're supposed to believe and then
we all believe it for some reason oh 50
of the zoos must close down slaughtering
the penguins it's a good idea it'll save
us
well that woman gave you some seriously
specific stuff as to what the
supervisors were doing
on some of these contested ballots they
were just giving it to the democrats
now her saying it in and of itself does
not make it true
but when they give sworn testimony then
that must be taken seriously as one of
the other women pointed out i think in
an arizona hearing yesterday
you know they sign these documents that
say if they're lying
that they could be taken to jail that
they could actually be jailed so these
are
these are decent american citizens who
are putting their butts on the line who
are being treated of course either
outright ignored by the media or being
you know treated like trash
um you decide you decide but
but the simple fact is that if we're
just going to ignore all of these people
like why should why should we ignore
that woman
okay who's doing a civic duty that she
doesn't have to do right she's doing
this because she wants to believe
in the integrity of the elections that i
think we would all want to believe in
why should we believe why should we not
believe her dismiss
the citizens while we listen to these
wannabe kings like garcetti and newsom
and de blasio and cuomo i mean we just
we just shouldn't so anyway the point is
there's still some things
moving along and if you are one of the
people who's just avoiding talking about
it or pretending that everyone who talks
about it
is a liar or a nut bag i think you got
another thing coming and that doesn't
mean that this
is going to end with everything being
overturned
but this idea that we should be afraid
to talk about certain things
is deeply dangerous before we get to the
next story the lockdown story which is
going to probably have me exploding out
of my chair
i want to talk to you guys about top
resume you know with today's high
unemployment rates and uncertain future
it's hard to plan ahead
let alone look for a new job here at the
reuben report we understand that that
struggle is real we just went through
the hiring process
we hired that guy he's right over there
his name's connor and we realized how
important it is to have a resume that
stands out among the rest
when it comes to writing your own resume
there's an unlimited number of things
that can go wrong and the cost of those
mistakes can be a missed opportunity
to secure your dream job top resume is
the world's premier resume writing
service
top resumes professional writers will
create a resume that showcases your
talents
achievements experience and career goals
using keywords
and skills that recruiters are seeking
top resume also offers a free
resume critique service including a
confidential comprehensive review
objective feedback on how well your
resume communicates your skills and
expertise
and personalized recommendations on how
to make your resume stronger
let the experts at top resume work with
you to create a job-winning resume that
gets noticed
find out how your resume stacks up go
to topresume.com ruben to get a free
resume review it's as simple as
uploading your resume to their site
you'll get a free evaluation and expert
advice
on how to make it stronger top resume is
also giving my listeners 15
off their professional resume writing
services so go to topresume.com
ruben today for your comprehensive
review and
15 off resume writing services if you
want to work with a pro that's
topresume.com
reuben and now back to me okay guys here
we go
you see this this is a pocket
constitution
this is the founding document that freed
us we've got the declaration of
independence we decided to be
independent from the king right no more
kings we're going to be a people
who rule ourselves and then we laid out
in this
i mean it's tiny and everyone should
read it everyone should read it
in this tiny little document that is
that is more brilliant and
has brought more freedom to more people
than any other man-made document
probably in the history of the world
we now find ourselves in 2020 in a time
when democratic mayors and it happens to
be pretty much only democratic mayors
and governors have decided that they are
allowed to ignore this thing
that they are allowed to tell you that
you can't go to work that they are
allowed to tell you that your mom can't
come over for lunch that they're allowed
to tell you
you can't take your kids to the movie
they they feel that they have now
decided
they have the power they have the power
to control every bit of your life and
guess what i'm not going to stand for it
and i don't think most people are going
to stand for it
so let's take a look at video from
yesterday this is los angeles mayor eric
garcetti a horrible human being
demanding that los angeles cancel
everything my message couldn't be
simpler
it's time to hunker down it's time to
cancel
everything and if it isn't essential
don't do it don't meet up with others
outside your household
don't host a gathering don't attend a
gathering
and following our targeted safer at home
order
if you're able to stay home stay home
just be smart and stay
apart that's our message tonight
and this is how we'll keep ourselves
safe this is how we will protect our
workers
our health heroes who i want to thank
who are on shift after shift after shift
with little light at the end of the
tunnel
los angeles mayor eric garcetti
go [ __ ] yourself
these are not good people these are not
good people what was the line there what
was live his little
his little rhyme just be smart and stay
apart they think we're children
they think that we are hamsters who can
live in a small cage
in a habit trail where occasionally we
can run from tube to tube
and pack a bunch of food in our cheeks
and then feed our families
this is no way to live and you don't
have to listen to these people
okay i this is not constitutional it is
not constitutional by the way i want to
pull up a picture as this man is telling
you
that you should stay home you should
wear masks you should watch your life
fall apart you should be depressed you
shouldn't be around people you love
we should ruin thanksgiving and we'll
ruin christmas soon enough
let's not forget that this douchebag and
i'm trying to bring the word douchebag
back
uh this is these people are douchebags
i'm not even totally sure what a
douchebag is but whatever a douchebag is
that's what these people are
uh this is eric garcetti in june let's
take a look
ah yes there's eric garcetti without a
mask
standing next to a woman without a mask
and they're at a protest
and somehow that that protest was not
called a super spreader event by cnn or
the new york times
as a matter of fact they were promoting
it and telling people this was their
civic duty
then of course when donald trump had
events these were super spreaders and
he's killing you
and everyone you know these are
ridiculous people
we did the big video yesterday the long
twitter thread about the hypocrisy
of these people i have no doubt that
eric garcetti is breaking his very rules
at the moment they don't want you riding
bikes
they don't want you they literally don't
want you taking walks i mean he's
basically saying don't take
a walk this is absolutely insane so
so let's dive in actually into a little
more
of the of this emergency public order
by these clown people this is from ktla
all residents within the city of los
angeles were ordered to remain in their
homes effective immediately
according to an emergency order issued
wednesday evening i guess aliens are
invading we got to stay home
the previous safer at home order was
withdrawn
and suspended superseded sorry by the
new one published wednesday which is
quote necessary for the protection of
life and property
in the city of los angeles the order
states it largely mirrors the existing
la county protocols that went into
effect monday
non-exempt businesses in the city were
ordered to cease
operations that require in-person
attendance of staff
however there is a broad list of
exceptions for various businesses
and workers deemed essential or exempt
people may lawfully leave their
residences only to engage in defined
essential activities all travel
including on foot
bicycle scooter motorcycle automobile or
public transit is prohibited they are
literally telling you you cannot take a
walk
travel on foot i was out there with
clyde
we walked he sniffed he peed
lord give me the strength this is this
is
absolute insanity and people
are rising up i'm going to show you a
couple videos in just a second about
people rising up all over the country
and guys watch v for vendetta tonight
you know maybe we'll do a
reubenreport.com
movie night we've done a couple of these
uh if you join us at reubenreport.com we
all watch a movie together and then we
do a big live chat maybe we'll do a huge
uh video chat as well maybe we'll just
get a couple hundred people or something
in on on a big zoom chat um because you
need to watch v for vendetta
and it it's an incredible movie and i
think we're getting to the point where
uh we're gonna have to start doing some
crazy [ __ ] because these people are
horrible and they want us locked in our
houses forever and i the reason i
mentioned
v for vendetta it's very much about this
sort of overreaching government thing
but one of the things that v says is
that uh
people should not fear their government
government should fear their people and
we're we're just about there guys
we're just about there and if you happen
to live in a freer state god bless you
and you're smarter than i am
and maybe i'm on my way florida how you
doing but
you should care about this too if we are
to remain the united states
of america but okay so so garcetti is
telling us all of this and
notice in all of this he doesn't really
show us any numbers there's no specific
things he doesn't explain why fifty
percent at zoos and
the rest of the nonsense so what do i
have to do well
again i'm not a journalist but i thought
you guys might appreciate some numbers
some actual numbers that might explain a
little bit of what's going on in the
world to you
so here's the la hospital capacity chart
and this is
actually rather amazing so what you're
seeing here
okay so you have two graphs there so on
the on the top graph
is the non-icu
bed situation so in essence what you're
seeing if you start at
5 31 so we'll start at the end of may
about 10
in non-icu so non-emergency beds
were taken okay 10 and then you can
follow the dates along
we at one point we got up to 15 then we
went down again we
load got it all the way down to about
six percent
in october and now we're right now as of
what is this as a basically last week
we're at 12
okay 12 percent of non-icu beds but
they're telling us this is the
the crisis of all crisis and hospitals
are going to be overrun
i lived near two hospitals that we we
drove by in the last couple days
the hospital that's right by my house is
basically completely empty it looks like
a ghost town
okay people aren't even going for for
other procedures right now because
they're so afraid
and then i went to a hospital that i
drove by a hospital on the way to home
depot that's about
maybe 10 miles away and it was basically
nobody in the parking lot or anything
else there's also a makeshift
coronavirus
testing facility an outdoor testing
facility it was completely empty
zero people there zero people there this
is just a couple days ago
uh the chart on the bottom if we could
throw that up again the chart on the
bottom
is um wait which one's non-icu
michael help me out here for just a sec
i'm looking at two things here
the uh okay the chart on the bottom is
the icu beds
so icu beds if you look at that in april
at 40 percent of i of beds in
icus right they were taken by covid
patients well then we did a nice job we
did a nice job and you can see this
basically going down
and now we're at 24 as of a week ago
24 i welcome you to look at this chart
yourself blow it up pause it take a look
you can see we have more beds than we
need that isn't to say that spikes can't
happen
that isn't to say that people can't get
sick that isn't to say that a hospital
couldn't be overrun have we had any
hospitals overrun in the united states
why haven't we seen massive outbreaks in
all these homeless encampments you know
here in the united states or here in the
united states here in los angeles
the people's republic of los angeles we
have homeless campaigns all over the
place
they build these tents these makeshift
cities sometimes you know i'll go under
a bridge on a saturday and i'll be like
oh look there's a new mini house under
the bridge
and the next day they put in a whole
extension and they have a whole new
house there and it's very impressive
that they can build them back quickly
well how come those people who by the
way
in this idiotic order by garcetti he
says
something like uh people who are
currently experiencing
homelessness are exempt from these
orders
if you're currently experiencing
homelessness you're exempt
okay you realize how bananas these
statements are so but why is it that
with all these
homeless encampments that we have in los
angeles run by a progressive
and in san francisco run by a
progressive why is it that
we haven't seen massive breakouts there
why is it that we haven't seen
where are five hospitals that have been
overrun in the united states
is is this odd does anyone think this is
odd i think it's a little odd
i'm starting to think it's a little odd
you see what i'm saying there uh but
again don't take my word for any of this
uh
you know we're going to put the link
let's put the link to this image
in the description so that people can
actually take a look but you will see we
have way more beds here in la
in icu and in non-icu than we need
at the moment and yet they are telling
us don't leave your house don't walk
your dog
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you okay let's move on to
segment three because people are
fighting back so now we can get to some
of the good stuff
segment three over here uh it's time to
defy these lockdown orders guys it
really
is time to to uh you know i'm sorry i i
cannot believe that that this is the
position that you people
have put me in and and i would say any
sort of
decent centrist freedom-loving american
which by the way i think is most of us
people have just absolutely had it so
this first video that i want to show you
comes out of michigan
and this is a restaurant owner who goes
off on to a local reporter
on what's going on with the lockdowns
let's take a look the details
on why the judge said no
javarius is everything okay okay my
government leaders have abandoned me
are you are you the owner of four
trillion dollars of
stimulus money i gave it to who special
interest groups and campaign donors i'm
dave morris i own the place
so what's going on what's going on you
know what's going on tell me you tell me
hey we got a government
that has taken the stimulus money they
gave it to special campaign
donors they gave it to special interest
they abandoned me
and they put me in a position where i
have to fight back
okay so do you feel that this is the
right thing to do absolutely
i feel everybody needs to stand up hey
listen there was enough money to give
every family
every family in this country twenty
thousand dollars
to go home for two months they chose to
give it to special interests
and campaign donors the kennedy space
center
and they abandoned us you could have
given me money i'd gladly walk away for
60 days and let this virus settle down
i'm not going to do it alone okay are
you going to continue to violate the
state's orders and stay open
state order this isn't an order this is
a conspiracy this is a tyranny
what do you want to tell other
restaurant owners who wake up stand up
this is america be free
i got patriots coming out
i'd vote for that guy too we got we got
the girl from earlier i'd vote for her
vote for this guy instead of these
clowns that we've got there's a couple
incredible quotes there now i'm not
i'm not confirming that everything he
said is absolutely true obviously but
the point is
that this this man who is just a decent
hard-working american a guy
who who decided to own a restaurant
which is one of the hardest businesses
something like 90 percent
of restaurants in good times fail in
their first year it's one of the most
difficult businesses
that you can possibly be in the blood
sweat and tears
that you have to do that i have friends
that own restaurants and i have friends
that tried to own restaurants and fail
this is not easy work
every moment of your life goes into that
and the government just locks you down
shuts you out says you can't do anything
moves the goal post so that you can
you know we've had a bunch of this in la
where just over the last couple weeks
people started building outdoor and
rooftop
um you know table areas and then what
happens well then they say you're not
even allowed to use that so you spend
money you don't even have
to go along with these orders that make
no sense and then they still shut you
down but a couple
a couple quotes there he said my
government leaders have abandoned me
he's in michigan which is gretchen
whitmore
which i'm you know she's getting her
botox there's no doubt about that during
all of this
and she's telling people they can't
garden uh so he's talking about her
they have put me in a position that i
have to fight
back all this guy wants to do is live
all he wants to do is put food on his
family's table
that's it he's not asking for anything
else and i thought the last one there
this isn't an order this is tyranny
stand up people they only have power if
we let them have power over us
it is it is as true as that what if they
really are just a paper tiger
it's just a bunch of lefty authoritarian
loons
who only have power if we keep thinking
they have power
they should be voted out there's no
doubt about that we have to vote these
people out
but in the meantime if we just start
going on about our lives and ignore
their orders
i think that will be good because you
know what if you open up your restaurant
and then the police officer
decides to ignore their orders i'm not
going to stop someone from trying to
feed their family
well then they have no power over us and
that would be much more american than
what's going on here
let's also show you a video this is from
yesterday this is in staten island and i
just love this video because i'm a new
yorker and you're going to see chef
andrew gruel
outside of mac's restaurant in staten
island
the well in essence the restaurant was
shut down by the
by the mayor by the governor of course
and then the the owner of max decided to
open up and he was gonna let people come
in and because they couldn't do commerce
their normal way
you could come in you could eat and then
you would just basically leave the
whatever amount of money you wanted to
leave they had plain closed police
officers basically go in so in effect
undercover police officers go in and
shut them down then
hundreds of people showed up to fight it
which they damn well should and we're
all for protest right
but apparently not these types of
protests uh so this is a video of chef
andrew gruel outside
of the protest at max
all right i'm out here in front of max
public house 130 lincoln avenue being
raided by the [ __ ] sheriff's
department
okay this tiny little place trying to
make a [ __ ] living okay
350 people in an airplane thousands of
planes
okay this close to each other costco's
open home depot people
lined up backed up with each other this
guy can't open his [ __ ] business
it's shame on you [ __ ] people shame
on everybody for letting this [ __ ]
happen
there should be a thousand people out
here right now when they're getting
[ __ ] raided by the goddamn gestapo
tomorrow is wednesday at six o'clock p.m
i want this [ __ ] street shut down
with ten thousand [ __ ] people because
if we don't show up
and show [ __ ] face we're gonna lose
this whole [ __ ] battle
disgusting you should all be [ __ ]
disgusted with yourselves
if they fear you they won't [ __ ] with
you you understand what i'm saying
get the [ __ ] out here tomorrow night
wednesday tomorrow night
six o'clock in front of max public house
this is disgusting
if they fear you they won't [ __ ] with
you that
is the freaking truth just to clarify
that video obviously was from tuesday
and then they did have hundreds of
people
show up yesterday it was pretty
spectacular we are going to see
more and more of this and it is the most
american thing you can do
as for me guys i am going to probably
walk my dog again later maybe i'm going
to buy
my employees lunch maybe we'll go go to
the supermarket together can a group of
people show up at a supermarket we'll
find out
in the freedom-loving haven of los
angeles
lordy lordy all right guys uh this ain't
going anywhere we're going to continue
oh
by the way uh i'll be going to dc
on tuesday don't want to say why just
yet but
that should be interesting dave rubin in
dc
on tuesday i've said too much already
but dave rubin will be in dc washington
d.c
on tuesday okay moving on uh
guys if you haven't seen it check out
part two of my interview with douglas
murray
he traveled all over the united states
and and traveled with with antifa
and he went to trump rallies and he just
does a an incredibly sobering
kind of clear review of where he thinks
the united states is at and and douglas
is just
one of the best that we that we've got
um all right that's it for me
and yes you know what we're gonna do
this reubenreport.com movie night v for
vendetta we're gonna do it in the next
two weeks or so
yeah definitely within the next two
weeks uh we will do it because i think
everyone needs to watch room report and
we do
we'll do a grind a giant group chat
where you can chat with me
on your phone maybe we'll do a video
chat as well we'll figure out exactly
the logistics all that i got to talk to
the team
but join us at reubenreport.com have a
great day everybody
fight for freedom wherever there's
trouble
gi joe is there goodbye